has anyone here been paid to hang out
with a guy raise your hand what what
what happened what did he pay you for he
to go on a date with him okay was it
like an ask did you have to put out or
was it just no no no no no not at all um
it was actually somebody that my friend
introduced me to and then he wrote to me
on Instagram and he asked me out and I
was like I'm busy I have to work and he
was like oh I'll pay you if you miss
work I'll pay you the money that you
made at work so I was like okay he give
me a little extra so yeah they with
confidence yeah they like they asked us
like a few of us to go to 11 and they
just gave us some 11's a strict CL so oh
how much how much money did you get I
got 500 500 two like 200 they just gave
it to us you didn't have to sleep with
them no